روبوت افتراضي للدردشه اطلق قبل اسابيع
وبات يقلق جوجل كثيرا في التفاصيل تم
اطلاق تشارجى بي تي لاستخدام المجاني في
نوفمبر الماضي وهو يعمل بواسطه الذكاء
الاصطناعي بطريقه تشبه الدماغ البشري وبات
يعتبر الافضل من نوعه التطبيق لديه مثلا
قد
ره
الكتابه والمقالات وتاليف نكات عن اي
موضوع يتم تحديده التطبيق جذب اكثر من
مليون مستخدم بعد خمسه ايام فقط من اطلاقه
لقدرته على فهم الاسئله وتقديم الاجابات
الحديث الان في الاوساط تكنولوجيه يدور
حول ما اذا كان بامكان التطبيق ان يحل محل
جوجل محرك البحث الاشهر بالفعل يشعر
بالقلق وبدا على ما يبدو بالتحرك المزيد
مع علاء
رغم الكثير من رواه من ردود الفعل
الايجابيه لتشات جي بي تي الا ان البعض
يجادل انه ليس مثاليا كما يبدو ويشككون في
قدرته على التحقق من دقه الاخبار
ولا يملك معلومات كافيه لما بعد 2000 20
وهو العام الذي تم فيه تغذيته بالبيانات
الشركه المطوره اوبن اي اي شات جي بي تي
نبهت المستخدمين من انه قد يقدم اجابات
خاطئه وقد يتبادل الردود العنصريه والاخطر
انه يقدم اجابات تبدو منطقيه لكنها ليست
الا محضه
الشركه تؤكد على ان المشروع لا يزال في
بدايته ترغب في معرفه اراء المستخدمين
وتقيماتهم لكي تتمكن من تحصينه وتطويله
ربما هذه هي الاسباب التي تجعل جوجل
مترددا تاجيل اطلاق روبوت محادثاته الذكي
على نطاق الواسع رغم الاعلان عنه منذ نحو
عامين خوفا من هامش الخطا المرتفع الذي قد
يضر بسمعه الشركه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من عمان ينضم الينا الخبير التقني رائد
سمور سيد رائد اهلا بك نحاول ان نفهم معك
بشكل مبسط ما هو التشادي بيتي روبوت
الدردشه او البرنامج الالي الذي وصفه ماسك
بانه جيد بشكل مخيف وما الفرق بين محرك
البحث جوجل
انا مضطر ارد على استاذ محمد همم
او هذه الاجهزه
العلم والتقدم العلمي وصل الى مرحله
الانسن الرقميه وصل الى مرحله مساحه
انما هي هي مرحله من التطور العلمي الاذن
والذي سوف ياتينا بتطور اكثر نعم اهم
تقنيه ما زالت في مرحله الخداد في في
عمليه
الخلط وفي عمليه التكوين بما ان نعم بما
انك تتحدث عن انسنت الذكاء للصناعي اليوم
ما حاجتنا لتشات جي بي تي لماذا نحتاجها
في كل شيء يا سيدي
الان سوف يغير من مناهج التعليم سوف يغير
من طريقه وادوات التعليم سوف يغير حتى على
مستوى البروفيسورز والدكاتره في الجامعات
الان اعاده التاهيل بالنسبه لهم ضروره
قسوه هذا سوف يغير من موضوع الكشف الطبي
سوف يغير من مسائل الصحيه سوف يؤثر في كل
مناحي الحياه لكن لكن التقنيه ما زالت
يعني هذا الدهون اللي احنا عايشينه ونحن
مازلنا في البدايات فما رايك عندما تنضج
الفكره وعندما يخرج المنتج النهائي ان
يقول تفضلوا هذا المنتج النهائي تفضل
واستخدموه سوف نصل الى مرحله الكمال في
الانسان الرقميه بمعنى انه يعني سوف تتحدث
مش معنى غبيه لا سوف تتحدث مع ما يشبه
الانسان بشكل كامل لكن ان يكن في حاله
التمام والكمال والمثاليه انا اعتقد ان
العقل البشري سوف يرفض كما رفضوه للانسان
محمد طيب هو برنامج دردشه والمعروف انه
ليس البرنامج الدردشه الاول من نوعه كان
هناك برامج اخرى للدردشه ما الذي يميز
ساجيبيتيه عن باقي البرامج الدردشه وهل
فعلا يكون غير موصول بالانترنت ويجيب
المحاور على كل اسئله ويعتذر
انه خالق لمحتوى هو هو يقوم على الحوار
معك من خلال ما تم تغذيته بمعلومات يقوم
بخوارزميات معينه يعطيك نتائج لهذا الحوار
هذا هذا هذا ما يميز انه هو يحترمك يا
انسان ويحترم حتى في بعض التجارب انه طلب
منهم مسائل قد تمسك الاخرين كان يعتبر
ويقول انا لا استطيع ان امس بكرامه اخرين
او بسمعه اخرين في عمليه
دردشه همم متقدم جدا تصل الى مرحله
التخاطب ال ال ال ال ال
العقيده يعني الموضوع شويه
معقد يعني شوي بس عشان نفهم انت بتقول انه
هو سيخلق المحتوى
وبتقول انه يجيبك على كل شيء طب شو بيفرق
عن اليكس مثلا عندك جهاز عم تقول له اليكس
همم شو الطقس اليوم اليكسا احكي لي ما
بعرف شو بس نفهم
وهذا يخلق المعلومه هذا يخلق المحتوى هذا
اعطيه انت عنوان لقصه يعطيك القصه تماما
وغير موجوده على الاطلاق يعني لا يقتبس من
الاخرين ولا ياتي بافكار من الاخرين اعطيه
فكره لمسلسل بيعطيكي حتى على مستوى
السيناريو اعطيه فكره لرسمه هو بيقوم برسم
هذه الرسمه اعطيه فكره لاي شيء بخطر على
بالك هو يحاول ان يعطيه
محتوى لكن تم تغذيه بهذه المعلومات
لكن طريقه عمل هذه المعلومات يمكن شويه
صعب
الشرح فيها هو يقوم بعمل عمليات ربط
بعمليات يمكن 100 مليون حركه بالثانيه من
خلال جمع المعلومات وبالتالي يعطيك
الاجابه احنا على مستوى عملنا في السيرفر
سكيورتي الكود كان ياخذ منه ساعات طوال
الان انا بطلب منه كود بيعطيني اياه خلال
ثواني هذه هذه هذه هذه الثوره في هذا
العلم انا اعتقد انه احنا يعني رايحين الى
نعم الى مرحله كما تحدث بدايه
احنا بنشكرك جزيلا شكرا للحديث تتمه دائما
معك ولكن
سمور شكرا